في عام 2011 وخلال فتره الزماله والتدريب
السريري
وفي مناوبه عطله نهايه الاسبوع
جاءت رساله على جهاز النداء الالي بان
هناك اطلاق نار ويوجد مصاب
كانت رساله عاديه
ولكن بعد لحظات
جاءت رساله اخرى بان عدد المصابين 10
العدد كان اكبر من المعتاد
والموضوع اصبح مقلق
خلال مده قياسيه
وصل المصابون الى المستشفى
وكان من ضمنهم عضوه الكونجرس الامريكي
التي كانت تجتمع مع مؤيديها في ما يعرف
الكونجرس عند الزاويه
لتناقش معهم مجموعه من المواضيع
تعرضت لاطلاق نار
من قبل المسلح
ادى الى اصابه مجموعه من الاشخاص ووفاه
البعض
اخترقت الرصاصه راس النائبه
وخرجت من الجهه الاخرى
ولولا مهاره الجراحين
لما تمكنت النائبه من النجاح
ولكن ربما تحتاج هذه الجمله
الى اضافه
فلولا سرعه الاستجابه للحادثه
ومهاره المسرفين
ومهاره المناوبين من الصيادله والاطباء
والممرضات والفريق الصحي
ومن بعد العمليه
مجهودات الفريق العلاجي
من مسؤولين عن العلاج الطبيعي والعلاج
الوظيفي والعلاج التنفسي
وحتى العلاج النفسي
ويقف ورائهم مجموعه كبيره من الاشخاص
من ضمنهم المسؤولين والاداريين الصحيين
الذين يقيسون مؤشرات الاداء
ويتاكدون من وجود الموظفين المناسبين في
المكان المناسب
وغيرهم
ويقف ايضا من خلفهم نظام صحي متكامل
والنظام اكاديمي متكامل
ربما
بعدها هؤلاء
لما تمكنت النائبه من النجاه
هنا ياتي سر العمل الجماعي
والتواصل مع الفريق
في ظل وجود اكثر من 10,000 مرض
و20 الف دواء بوصفه
وعشرات الالاف الادويه بدون وصفه
اصبح الموضوع يشكل تحدي حقيقي على الفريق
الصحي
وما لم يعمل الفريق
على تشكيل شبكه حمايه وانقاذ
ستصبح المخرجات الصحيه تتاثر سلبا
منذ التجربه التي مررت بها
يوم اطلاق النار
ايقنت اهميه ان يكون التعليم البيني جزءا
اساسيا في نظام التعليم الطبي
كان علينا التفكير خارج الصندوق
لجعل التعليم البيني في المناهج الصحيه
وايضا تقديم الرعايه الصحيه بشكل متكامل
تبادل العمل على تصميم نموذج رعايه
تكامليه في عيادات القلب
شارك فيه
طبيب استشاري
وممرضه
اخصائيه تغذيه والصيدليه
ونجحت التجربه
لمتابعه مرضى قصور القلب
من الناحيه الاخرى
وفيما يتعلق بالتعليم الطبي
انشانا وحده التعليم
البيني بين التخصصات الصحيه والتي تتكون
من اعضاء من افراد الفريق الصحي المختلفين
مسافعله اليوم هو التحدث قليلا عن بعض
التحديات التي واجهناها
وسابدا بالنظام الصحي
فعلى الرغم من وجود كفاءات بمستويات
عالميه
ومستويات رائعه الى ان النظام ارتعايه
الصحيه احيانا لا يساعد هذه الكفاءات
للعمل باقصى طاقتها
يواجه الطبيب على سبيل المثال صعوبه
احيانا في التواصل مع الصيدلي للحصول على
قائمه الادويه التي يحصل عليها المريض من
عده اطباء ومن عده مستشفيات
والعكس صحيح
لا يتمكن عاده الصيدلي من التواصل مع
الطبيب عند وجود سؤال عن الوصفه الطبيه او
الجرعه او الدواء
وايضا ما يجعل المهمه اصعب هو عدم وجود
نظام معلومات تكنولوجيا تكنولوجيا
المعلومات مشترك بين الجهتين
الثاني هو التجربه الصحيه
من المهمه العمل على توحيد التجربه وايضا
توحيد التكلفه
يجب ان نستفيد
بالطبع بالتجارب العالميه ولكن ايضا
نضع في الحسبان ان لكل منطقه خصوصيتها
ولكن لابد ان تكون الانظمه التي توحد اليه
التعامل مع مجموعه من الامراض
تضم كافه المتطلبات التي تحتاجها المنشاه
للتعامل مع هذه الامراض التي من الممكن ان
تكون فريق طبي متكامل
فاذا حضر احدكم سباق الفورميلا
ووجد سائق الفورما لا يعتمد على شخص واحد
واستاذ السباق بعجوبه
بالتاكيد غالبا لن يحصل على مراكز متقدمه
مقارنه بذلك الفريق الذي يحتوي على مجموعه
من الافراد لكل شخص منهم عمل مختلف
الثالث والتحدي الاخير هو صعوبه تعليم
طلاب المهن الصحيه المختلفه
لكل تخصص جدول ومتطلبات واوقات مختلفه
ولكن هنا ارغب في طرح مثال
وهو عندما قمنا باجراء دراسه لاخذ مرئيات
طلاب الدراسات في التخصصات الصحيه
المختلفه
وما مدى تاثير عملهم سويا كانت الاجابه
دائما بالاجماع ان عمل الطلاب في التخصصات
الصحيه سويا ادى الى حل المشكله بشكل افضل
وبشكل اسرع
وبدون المشاكل التي تواجههم عندما لا
يقومون بالتواصل سويا
السر هو ايجاد نقطه الالتقاء والعمل عليها
كل شخص بارع في تخصصه
ولكن اذا لم يجد الدعم من الفريق
ربما لم تظهر براعته بالكامل
سيكون الطبيب الجراح الماهر في تخصص
العظام
ربما لا تكلل عمليته بالنجاح بسبب عدم
التواصل وعدم وجود المعالج الطبيعي
قمنا بتخريج مراد فريق طبي
واطباء
وصيادله وممرضين عظماء
ولكننا لم نعلمهم كيفيه العمل معا
ما هي الحلول المقترحه
اولا ابدا بتغيير نفسك
اذا كان بامكانك تغيير نفسك فيما انت تعرف
يمكنك البدء في تغيير العالم وجعله افضل
كن على استعداد
لمواجهه التحديات في الامر ليس بالموضوع
السهل
ابدا اليوم بدون تاخير
كل ما تحتاجه للتغيير هو البدايه والبذره
بالاعتناء
ستنبت وتكبر
وتزدهر ولكنها تحتاج الى الكثير من الصبر
حدد هدفك
ويجعله تغيير البيئه
بحيث تزيد المعرفه وبدل من ان يكون شخص
راي شخص واحد هو السائد يصبح التعلم من
الجميع هو المحور
ومعرفه ان الجميع هدف واحد وهو علاج
المريض
ويبقى احد اهم الاشياء التي يجب علي ان
تركز عليها هو ان تعرف امكانياتك جيدا
وتطورها وتعرف ما يمكنك اضافته للفريق
تعرف جيدا على نقاط قوه ونقاط ضعفك
واحرص دائما على اجراء تقييم ذاتي لنفسك
بحيث تعمل على ان يكون فريقك باليوم هو
افضل من فريقك بالامس
وفريقك غدا افضل من فريقك اليوم شكرا لكم
[تصفيق]